I'm Abby hornacek I'm Ben Dominic I'm
Dana Perino and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday March 24th 2023
three-week lawmakers took Tick-Tock to
task on Capitol Hill as Xi Jinping
concluded his Summit with Russia's
Vladimir Putin the house Foreign Affairs
committee chairman says Washington must
wake up to our greatest foreign threat
this is a the biggest you know threat I
see is really long term is the Chinese
Communist party I'm Chris Foster Tick
Tock CEO says the video sharing platform
is safe and not a Chinese government
tool lawmakers across the board appear
unconvinced saying listen ultimately
this company is under the control of the
CCP in one way or the other and it
doesn't have America's best interests at
heart we're speaking the Fox News Sunday
host Shannon bream and I'm Jason
Chaffetz I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
Republicans and Democrats in Washington
don't agree on much of anything and yet
both sides seem awfully concerned about
the social media platform tick tock
house Energy and Commerce chair
Republican Kathy McMorris Rogers said a
serious tone with Tick Tock CEO
testifying before her committee Tick
Tock has repeatedly chosen the path for
more control more surveillance and more
manipulation then it was California
Democrat Congressman Tony Cardenas going
after tick tock CEO Chuchu is there a
corporation that has any Authority above
tick tock tick tock is the subsidiary of
by dance which is founded by a Chinese
founder is a Chinese company I
frequently have this discussions with
others on what is a company that is now
global that's okay I prefer you answer
the question and stop dancing verbally
on it also in the hot seat Thursday
Secretary of State Tony blinken before
the house Foreign Affairs committee the
focus there the bite administration's
awkward withdrawal from Afghanistan
there are several Americans who are
being detained by the uh the Taliban we
are working to secure their freedom
former Green Beret and Florida
Republican Congressman Michael Waltz
says the Biden Administration turned its
back on America's trusted friends they
left over 80 000 of our allies who stood
and fought with us and the Taliban right
now using data that we left behind
Biometrics fingerprints Registries are
hunting them down and killing them as we
speak another hot story this week the
growing Unholy alliance between China
and Russia after China's leader Xi
Jinping paid a visit to Moscow earlier
this week House china committee chairman
Republican Mike Gallagher took note of
it on Fox's America's Newsroom we Face a
very determined competitor in the form
of the Chinese Communist party that
wants to undermine our sovereignty wants
to undermine our alliances and is
committing genocide something we thought
was Unthinkable in the modern era top
lawmakers are watching to see if talks
between Xi Jinping of China in Vladimir
Putin of Russia produce any meaningful
results I think it's a major concern I
you know this goes back to the Beijing
Olympics when Mr Putin and chairman XI
met Texas Congressman Michael McCall a
republican is Chairman of the house
Foreign Affairs committee to discuss
their unlimited partnership they call
the the sun holy Alliance talked about
invading Ukraine and we're seeing you
know Mike we're seeing more and more
evidence of at least support from I know
they buy all Russian energy to finance
and support the war effort but now we're
starting to see you know components
going in software for surveillance
drones and I'm afraid after this meeting
which you're going to see I believe Mr
Putin was begging him to give him lethal
weapons because he's running out of his
stock supply and he's already begged
Iran in North Korea and they're
delivering and I think the next step is
going to be you're going to see China
putting lethal weapons into the conflict
so I think it's a great concern uh you
know talk to the Secretary of State
about this you know at the hearing but
also privately and how we need to call
them out on this we need to think about
sanctions and and I would recommend that
we declassify you know the documents
pertaining to this to the American
people have a better understanding about
this Alliance
in terms of the alliance what's the
impact you mentioned Ukraine but also
Taiwan well I think what happens in
Ukraine has a direct impact on Taiwan it
directly impacts chairman she's
calculations on whether to as he calls
it reunify Taiwan with China by an
invasion
um this is a the biggest uh you know
threat I see is really long term is the
Chinese Communist party I do think
chairman she is going to try to
influence the election that will come up
the presidential election next January
so he could take it over without a shot
fired if he's not successful then I
think he'll go to you know this military
blockade scenario with a full-fledged
military invasion
there was some talk that President XI
you know who was claiming his goal is to
be a neutral mediator in the conflict
between Russia and Ukraine would call
President Vladimir zielinski while he
was visiting Moscow do you think there's
anything to that or do you think he's
just merely bluffing on the
international stage I think it's it's
deception I mean I don't see how China
can be an objective arbiter
and and a peacemaker in a war that
they're directly involved in as an ally
of Moscow and Putin so and it's all four
of them involved in this I mean Iran's
you know putting their Iranian drones in
Crimea that are causing damage North
Korea sending artillery shells and so I
I mean to me it's kind of laughable that
they could be the objective Arbiter
again in a conflict that they're
directly on the side of Russia go on
what are your concerns about these
outside weapons coming in in terms of
the impact on the war on Ukraine does it
just drag it out longer and longer yeah
that is my concern I I've been very
critical of this Administration for you
know slow walking the pace of the
weapons we should have been putting
these weapons in before the invasion for
deterrence
um and they've just been incredibly slow
had we given them everything we have to
date a year ago we probably in a very
different situation but if you're just
going to trickle the weapons in just
enough to get them by then my concern is
it drags out and that's precisely what
Putin wants and he knows that that will
also impact probably the will of the
American people but also the will of our
European Partners The Tick Tock CEO is
on Capitol Hill testifying to lawmakers
that the app is safe and secure and
should not be banned he promised more
transparency and so they're working to
protect U.S user data from unauthorized
foreign data what should we make of this
do you buy it yeah I don't you know tick
tock's on a charm offensive and they
have actually they have these
influencers in Washington right now that
make all this money off Tick Tock which
I find interesting but the bottom line
is you know Congress banned the app for
ourselves but we're allowing it to be
used by our children primarily and it is
a back door into your iPhone it can't
access your data it can access your
keystrokes your passwords it can
influence you with the algorithms you
know until uh you know bite dance is
willing to completely move out of
Beijing uh I will not be satisfied I
think one of the issues here is that
they still want the algorithms operated
out of Beijing and to me that's you know
it's not just me it's every National
Security you know advisor in this
Administration has talked about what a
threat it is you know from the CIA
director you know to the FBI director
and I agree with them uh you know I
marked up and passed out of my AI
committee a bill that we give the
Constitutional framework to move forward
to authorize the president to ban Tick
Tock in the United States I think
ideally what you want to see is an
American owned and operated company that
can do the social media so Republicans
and Democrats in Washington don't agree
on much these days but do you think this
idea of banning Tick-Tock could be
something where both sides come together
and say you know what we've got to
protect our kids we've got to protect
our country you know
those areas where we have really a great
opportunity to be bipartisan you know I
chaired the giant task force we had a
lot of bipartisan recommendations we
passed a lot of bills but to your point
I really do think there is a an
opportunity to do what's best for
America uh rather than putting our
partisan Stripes ahead of that a big
focus of Thursday's hearing was
accountability for foreign policy
mistakes and it led to an intense
exchange with Secretary of State blinken
when you asked for the state department
to hand over an Afghanistan descent
cable a document that warned about the
likelihood of a Taliban takeover if the
U.S executed a withdrawal tell us why
you think this descent cable is so
important well it's important to the
veterans and the Gold Star Mothers it's
important to get answers as to what
happened this is a very rare thing
that's done within the state department
where you have a descent cable that can
go to the Secretary of State directly
out of the embassy in this case Kabul 23
Embassy employees dissented to the
policy of this Administration we want to
see that cable and we think of the
American people are entitled to see that
cable I I'm giving the secretary a
deadline of Monday close the business uh
before you know I serve a subpoena
because I want to know what the embassy
what their objections were to the
policies being implemented at that time
many of which you know resulted in the
deaths of you know 13 service men and
women 140 Afghans and 50 wounded by the
suicide bomber which by the way Mike you
know we had this compelling powerful
testimony from the marine sergeant of
Vargas Andrews about how he had the
suicide bomber in his sights and met
with his team and they ran it up the
chain of command and were not given
authority to engage or permission to
engage the suicide bomber think about
the difference that would have made had
they been able would take out the threat
before that bomb went off and I think
very dramatically today we had the
mother you know of the marine sergeant
female officer who was actually killed
and and died that day and it was very
emotional
what do you think that document would
tell us about the mistakes of the Afghan
withdrawal how damning would it be do
you think well I think when you have
your diplomats on the ground in Kabul 23
of them with the Descent cable right I
think it's going to be a very
eye-opening document I think it'll be
very damaging reflection on the
administration and the poor policy
decisions that were made which is
precisely Mike why they don't want to
turn it over we've tried to do this in a
Cooperative way but I think the fact
that they're so nervous about turning it
over probably speaks volumes and I think
that's why you know if they refuse to do
it I will move forward with the subpoena
because it's too important we need to
know what our diplomats on the ground
what were their objections to this
administration's policies you made
reference to a former Ambassador who is
calling BS on the byte administration's
cover-up of this descent cable tell us
about that well it's interesting so they
cite as a precedent to not produce The
Descent Cable in 1979 descent cable
under 100 Andrea Kissinger Kissinger
didn't want it you know produced to
Congress because it was embarrassing
probably like this one
so we called the former Ambassador who
wrote that descent cable back in 1979
and in his words not mine Mikey he said
that's bull so I repeated the
ambassador's words to the Secretary of
State that he thought it was both that
the American people in Congress have
every right to see a dissenting cable
particularly in something of this
magnitude where he had 13 service men
and women killed I think those families
and the families of the others who died
and were wounded have the right to know
what the objections were to the policies
that led to such a catastrophic uh event
at the Abbey Gate House Foreign Affairs
chairman Michael McCall of the great
state of Texas thank you so much for
your time on a very busy week we
appreciate it no thanks Mike thanks for
having me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Jason Chaffetz with your Fox
News commentary coming up
Tick Tock CEO Shoji Chu tells Congress
the video sharing platforms nothing to
worry about there are more than 150
million Americans who love our platform
and we know we have a responsibility to
protect them you testify for the house
Energy and Commerce Committee and denies
the Chinese government uses Tick Tock to
collect information on and manipulate
Americans including teenagers he says
tick tock's parent company bite dances
not an agent of China or any other
country Washington State Republican
Kathy McMorris Rogers isn't buying it
your platform should be banned
I expect today you'll say anything to
avoid this outcome the Biden
Administration wants tick tocks sold the
Chinese government says it's opposed to
that there's so few things that there's
really strong bipartisanship on in
Washington right now and China is one of
them Shannon bream's the host of Fox
News Sunday Tick Tock is viewed as
something obviously based in China they
say we've got separate business
operations that deal with the U.S
markets lawmakers across the board
appear unconvinced saying listen
ultimately this company is under the
control of the CCP in one way or the
other and it doesn't have America's best
interests at heart so yes you are going
to Tick-Tock off the younger people nice
if you do this but I think that it's
looking more and more increasingly like
that's going to happen if you were going
to launch a campaign to make the
children of your enemies stupider there
would be worse ways to do it I
understand that the Chinese version of
tick tock for example has a 40 limit
time limit for kids built in when you
sign up and the algorithm puts out
actually more educational videos and
science experiments and stuff like that
as opposed to and look I got nothing
against funny dancing videos too but the
way it works is you get these little you
get these dopamine hits and they just
keep coming and coming and coming and
it's addictive yeah they do I think we
all know that with any kind of social
media that you use you have to be really
disciplined and I think it's much harder
for young brains and young kids who this
is the world they operate in it's a
virtual world
um how many likes can I get did you see
the latest dance craze I'm gonna do it
now I'm gonna do a video and put it on
Tick Tock I mean I sat behind a teenager
on a plane a week or so ago and just
watching them through the seats just
fling through Tick Tock after tick tock
after tick tock I mean I don't know how
you wouldn't be just destroying your
ability to have an attention span
um the way that they were going through
this and I think China knows that like
you said the algorithms for their kids
in their country are look at this
engineering student winning a trophy for
this you a very intricate project that
they put together and yes us it's like
you know half dressed twerking right
one of our producers here for this show
um is Young ish not not a teenager
anymore but um she wants it banned
because she can't trust herself she
can't get herself off yeah right she
wants them she wants them to take it
away from her right please help me yeah
um it's the same thing we heard Josh
Hawley Senator Josh Hawley not long ago
talking about banning and um you know
reigning in time limits and different
kinds of things and getting rid of some
social media altogether and he said
parents actually want us to do this
because then they can point to us and
say sorry federal government has banned
XYZ or federal government says you can
only be on for a certain amount of time
um he's like they want us to be able to
say you know it's the feds who are the
bad guys but they want the tools so yeah
I think we all realize we need a little
help writing in our time on various
websites and apps and some other social
media time killer will come along to
replace it with the with the kids I'm
sure but but it won't be tied to the
Chinese government well it may not or I
think about the kids are so stinking
smart they'll find a way around the
Bands okay you know you can hide IP
addresses and do all kinds of things so
I I don't underestimate the kids
abilities to get to what they want to do
speaking of China China's president she
uh it's been a few days in Russia this
week meeting with uh Russian President
Vladimir Putin that Alliance seems to um
be strengthening could be a problem for
the rest of the world not China or
Russia including the United States yeah
and they want to be that partner for
that are looking for loans that are
looking for development that don't have
their own resources you know we've seen
that with China in a lot of places in
Africa and across the world to say like
oh let us come in and help with XYZ
um if other people won't lend or other
people won't help you with
infrastructure we will and um they're
very smart about it obviously and any
time that we are not viewing them as a
direct threat maybe not okay militarily
to the U.S Homeland but in you know the
sense of building these relationships
and allies and alliances and technology
and embedding themselves in other
people's culture and finances and
everything else I mean we're missing the
opportunity now they're you know again
this is a bipartisan concern on the hill
and there have been people on both sides
of the aisle for years who have been
saying we're not taking these threats
from China seriously enough I think
about Senator Mark Warner Democrat who
chairs the Senate Intel committee there
have been people raising the red flag
and there are others who say you know
it's fine we're over hyping it it's not
that big of a deal this is just the
normal course of business in the world
Shannon are you following the Federal
Reserve tightrope they're trying to get
inflation down uh without hurting growth
they're now causing bank failures it's a
very tough plane to land it is and I
wish I'd paid closer attention in my
econ classes uh in college some really
great professors and I'm like trying to
dig and scrape and remember how all of
these things are interconnected and kind
of The Dominoes that are out there so we
get a quarter point rate hike from the
FED as everybody's looking at them will
they slow down will they stop the rate
hikes are there going to be reversals at
some point and they do have not only the
monster of inflation to deal with but as
you mentioned these Bank issues the
concerns about contagion we are globally
interconnected all over the world with
banking systems finances inflation all
of those things have Ripple effects
everywhere so interesting to see the
treasury secretary seem like she was
sort of you know throwing the Fed chair
under the bus a little bit about how
he's managed this but what it means for
now is that the cost of borrowing money
and getting loans on cars and houses and
anything else it's going to be more
expensive
um so Shannon president Trump uh had
said that he was going to be he thought
he was going to be arrested this past
Tuesday that now is not coming to
fruition it's not going to happen until
at least next week the grand jury has
had a couple sessions delayed now and
some sometimes this happens it's a lot
of people to Wrangle you know somebody
has a funeral somebody gets covid or
whatever we don't really know what's
going on behind the scenes yeah and
there's also some last minute info
that's come forward you've got this
attorney Robert Costello Who's come
forward to say that he was representing
or working with Michael Cohen at some
capacity at some point Cohen's denying
that does this guy never represented me
but Costello was watching from the
outside and said what I was hearing
coming from the grander testimony and
from what Michael Cohen had said I felt
like he wasn't telling the truth and I
thought it was my duty to come forward
and share what I knew he also says you
know the grand jury has seen maybe six
relevant emails where there he says more
than 300 and he says I've provided those
the members of the grand jury should see
that so he spent time with them this
week testifying now we have this letter
that has surfaced that appears to come
from the time when Michael Cohen was
still in good graces and working with
the Trump organization denying that the
president had reimbursed his money so
obviously we're trying to verify all of
these letters in the validity of those
kinds of things but it also is from a
different time period before Michael
Cohen himself came forward and gave very
different testimony so this attorney
Robert Costello says listen if you're
pinning this hole if Alvin brag is
pinning this whole thing on Michael
Cohen's testimony he's not the best
witness and there are issues of veracity
was he telling the truth then or is he
telling the truth now who knows we don't
know what happens behind closed doors
but maybe that has been what has put the
grand jury in a little bit of a tailspin
or a delay we don't know how the jurors
were impacted by that testimony from
Costello and whether they're going to
get a look at this letter from 2018 for
Michael Cohen
um we've talked a lot about a race not
officially happening between the former
president and Ron DeSantis Florida's
governor who hasn't again officially
declared but we still sort of talk about
him as if he's the he's the main um the
main guy behind Trump in that race for
now at least um that's escalated a
little in the past week a little more
insults from both sides yeah and it's
interesting because as you said Governor
DeSantis
officially in but there have been packs
and infrastructures and things put into
place so that if he does make a decision
he hits the ground running I mean the
money's in place the donors are in place
the organization is in place
um he can't officially cooperate with
any of that stuff until he's made a
decision if he's gonna run there's been
a lot of talk that he wants to get
through the legislative session there in
Florida they've got a law on the books
it says something about not holding
State office while you're running for
federal office and you know there may be
a fix to that legislatively who knows
but I do think
um you know everybody assumes that
DeSantis is going to get in and so the
sparring back and forth is only going to
heat up
um he's walking a fine line by defending
the president against the former
president against things like the Alvin
Bragg
um you know potential prosecution
indictment that kind of thing while also
throwing in lines like well I personally
can't speak to what it's like to pay off
a porn star allegedly for an
indiscretion so it's clear that these
two are going to get their digs in at
each other the former president much
more head-on going after the governor
and if they end up on a debate stage or
truly in a campaign against each other
it's inevitable they're going to have to
do this but in the meantime I think the
governor is trying to keep some of his
powder dry until he's if he is
officially in the race another guy we've
talked about is a potential candidate
now is looking even more potentially
like a candidate a South Carolina
Republican senator Tim Scott yes
um he has scheduled this Summit April
14th and 15th with what he's calling a
political update on that uh that on that
Saturday the 15th so maybe we'll hear
from you then yeah and you know he spent
a lot of time in Iowa New Hampshire of
course South Carolina his own home state
which is an important early State and
I've had a lot of conversations with him
about kind of this uh take that he has
on can we take the high road can we have
a conversation about faith and family
and restoring our trust in our fellow
Americans which I think a lot of people
think sounds good and of course they're
for that but is there a lane to run in a
nasty primary with that message will it
work and I think he and his team have
really been trying to see you know he
said to me he genuinely wants to see
what the reaction is in those early
States about whether people would get
behind something like that or if it's
just like yes I aspire to that it feels
good but would it really work head to
head against former president Trump I
don't know but I think that he is in
deep serious consideration he's also
very effusive in his praise of former
president Trump maybe they end up on a
ticket together Shannon bream host of
Fox News Sunday thanks have a good one
foreign
[Music]
co-host of Fox and Friends Weekend join
me as I share my thoughts on a wide
range of topics from Sports and pop
culture to politics and business so will
Kane podcast subscribe and listen now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary face and Chaffetz
what's on your mind to oversight or not
oversight that's always the question
usually the party that's in power in the
white house does not like the other
party conducting oversight into the
Affairs of how the executive branches is
running their business but back in 1814
interestingly enough they started what
is today's oversight committee the idea
was that for every government
expenditure Congress would be able to go
in and look and see how this was done
this committee expanded it contracted it
morphed into different names and back in
the mid 1800s Abraham Lincoln actually
joined this committee he was known as
spotty because he didn't believe that
the president was being truthful about
where the Mexican-American War was
fought did the Mexican-American War
actually start where the president said
it did he wanted to know the exact spot
of where it happened thus you've had
this kind of rigorous oversight time and
time again the United States is
different we're self-critical we take a
hard look we should be going back and
looking at the origins of covet what's
going on at the border what's been
happening with the banking industry and
how we're spending these trillions of
dollars of the American people's money
oversight is invigorating it's
Illuminating and it's supposed to allow
us the American people to make sure that
we don't make the same mistakes again
I'm sure it's uncomfortable for the
people that are on the receiving end of
this oversight but it is what
differentiates Us in the United States
of America we are self-critical and we
need to continue to do it even though it
may cause and be uncomfortable for some
I'm Jason Chaffetz the former chairman
of the house oversight committee and the
host of the Jason in the house podcast
[Music]
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
I'm Emily compagno and this is the fox
True Crime podcast bringing you closer
to the story than you ever thought
possible subscribe at foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts these
are the stories that keep you up at
night
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes